[موسيقى]
الاعداد الصناعي هو كالتالي لدينا ثلاث
حظائر نقوم في المحطه الاولى بالتعديلات
الهيكليه وتركيب القطع الكبير والالواح ثم
النظام وبعد ذلك تركيب الاسلاك من اجل
اعداد الطائره وفي هذه المرحله يجب ان
تكون الطائره معلقه بسبب الشد الكبير على
الهيكلتين
[موسيقى]
وما نقوم به في هذه المرحله هو تركيب نظام
والاسلاك والقطاع والجهاز الاساسي لقدرات
التزود بالوقود جونا وكذلك محطه المشغل
حيث يتمكن مشغل اعاده التعبئه بالوقود جوا
من توجيه الخرطوم جوا لتعبئه الوقود بنجاح
وبعد ذلك ننتقل الى الاختبار الارضي
الداخلي والخارجي قبل ان نذهب الى خط
الطيران واجراء اختبارات الطيران ثم تسليم
الطائرات الى العميل
[موسيقى]
جدا لانها تعتمد على نوع المهمه التي يرغب
العميل بادائها المهمه النموذجيه قد تشمل
اربع طائرات في مهمه اعاده التعبئه
بالوقود الى جانب طائره ام ار تي تي ومره
اخرى الامر يعتمد بشكل كبير على الوقود
داخل الطائره
[موسيقى]